what's going on everyone
Peter Combofiend Rose is here to talk to
you about yang in Ultra Street Fighter 4
ning has been working hard to steal the
spotlight from his high-flying brother
so let's see if the changes he received
this time around will finally allow him
to do so
yang players informed us that since yang
is primarily a ground character he
should be able to close in on the
opponents that much faster to address
this his walk speed has been increased a
bit from his AE 2012 version being
steady light kick is one of his best
tools for playing a range game as well
as punishing attacks that push being out
unfortunately it came out too slow for
it to be all that effective to fix this
the first and light kick now comes out a
little bit faster than it used to which
will definitely help him punish attacks
faster
gangs jumping middle kick was one of the
best tools in Street Fighter 4 arcade
edition and quite possibly one of the
strongest crossed-up attacks in the
entire Street Fighter 4 series
unfortunately it was changed for the
worst in a II 2012 to the point where it
was almost useless which made a lot of
young players pretty sad in an effort to
make this attack better but not as good
as it was an AE because it was much too
strong the hitbox has been increased to
allow for a more consistent cross hook
gangs for standing middle punch is
considered a decent attack by yang
players outside of the fact that it was
not special cancelable as his range
attack options are limited his first
time middle punch is now special
cancelable to allow him to play a more
range based game Yang's command Farrell
provided him too much reward as a damage
after a successful command grab was the
same as if the opponent wasn't blocked
as this is essentially an attack one
point of damage has been added when the
throw is successful this means that all
additional hits following the throw will
now do less damage Yang's Mendte strikes
are as primary combo ender yet they did
not do all that much damage there by
making yang seem pretty weak to address
this the third hint of his Madsen
strikes now do a bit more damage than
they used to in a 2012 Yang's lights mqt
attack was quite useful in that it's an
invincibility and advantage on block 1
cancel
allow Inc to reverse the opponent's
offense that will do to the high reward
and low risk associated with his attack
the advantage on guard when counseled
has been reduced be careful when
throwing this out or face big damage
yang has improved dramatically from AE
2012 his primary issues of damage and
movement have all been addressed which
means that he's only gotten stronger
this time around he still has lower
vitality than the rest of the cast but
with his tweaks he'll be dishing out
damage with the bestop